[Music]
I oh look what the Cat Dragged In good
afternoon
e how's your day Dad it was a day just
another day my day was a doozy it's one
of those days you never
forget listen up this young lady is our
new prison psychologist
she may be easy on the eyes but I assure
you she is very
smart I'm Rebecca I
know I don't think I caught your
name
oopsie nasty habit that's why I like it
I live a little differently than most
people they probably scared
you prison is no place for you young
lady you got a big life ahead of you I'm
sure I'm just kind of average I think do
you really think you're a normal
person I know you have brilliant
dreams alen may I confide in you people
are so ashamed of their
desires I have my own
ideas kind
ideas you can never tell anyone do you
understand promise me okay
that will make you
crazy that will make you
pill can't imagine you with a knife can
you imagine me with a
gun that's very good I yeah I can see
it you're different these
days almost interesting secrets and lies
some things are so
twisted
the only way I ask for someone to
[Music]
die that was a great
trick